This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. And I'm Ben Brock Johnson from the WBUR podcast, Endless Thread. And today we're bringing you the first episode for our new collaborative series called Hidden Levels. It's about how the world of video games has changed the world beyond video games. In the next six episodes, we'll get deep into how games are made and designed. everything from the history of the joystick to how nature is faithfully recreated in the digital world to a dispatch from the front lines of the console wars. So, Roman, when did video games first change your world?
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。我是来自 WBUR 播客《Endless Thread》的本·布洛克·约翰逊（Ben Brock Johnson）。今天，我们将为您带来全新合作系列节目《Hidden Levels》的第一集。本系列探讨了电子游戏世界如何改变了游戏之外的世界。在接下来的六集里，我们将深入探讨游戏的制作与设计：从操纵杆的历史，到大自然如何在数字世界中被逼真地重现，再到主机大战前线的战地报道。那么，罗曼，电子游戏最早是在什么时候改变了你的世界的？
I mean, probably when I was in elementary school in the 80s, the arcade that I went to the most was a small section in a skating rink in Newark, Ohio. And so I first learned playing video games on roller skates, actually. That sounds impressive. How about you? I think, you know, I didn't have an arcade spot, but one memory that is really strong for me is I had the luck. My brother actually brought me to Japan when I was 12 years old, and I was really lucky to do that.
我想，大概是在 80 年代的读小学的时候吧，我经常去的游乐厅是俄亥俄州纽瓦克市一个溜冰场里的一小块区域。所以，实际上我最早是在轮滑鞋上学会玩电子游戏的。听起来真酷。你呢？我觉得吧，虽然我没有那种常去的游乐厅，但有一段记忆对我来说非常深刻，那就是我很幸运。我 12 岁的时候，我哥哥带我去了日本，我真的觉得自己太幸运了。
It blew my mind in so many ways, but I went into a real deal Japanese arcade while I was there, and it was so incredible. I mean, the different kinds of games you could play, the sites, really the sounds too. we are audio people, Roman. I love sound first and foremost. And that's what I think of sometimes when I think of video games. Absolutely. I'm exactly the same way. And there's something really special about designing game sounds so that it can cut through the din of all the other arcade games
那次经历在许多方面都让我大开眼界。我在那里进了一家真正的日本街机厅，简直太不可思议了。我是说，你可以玩的各种游戏、那些视觉景象，还有声音，真的。我们都是做音频的人，罗曼。我首先最爱的就是声音。有时每当我想到电子游戏时，脑海里浮现的就是这些。绝对的。我完全一样。而且，设计游戏音效时有一种非常特殊的地方，那就是它必须能够穿透所有其他街机游戏的喧嚣，
and kind of draw you to the machine. Do you have a favorite sound that you think of when you think of video game sounds? I mean, my favorite is there used to be this really big arcade game called Gauntlet that had like four joysticks on it so you can play four different characters. And one of the sounds that the sort of game announcer said was elf needs food badly elf needs food badly or elf is about to die and i think about elf needs food badly every time i'm hungry literally every day of my life since i played gauntlet i think about this game sound how about you what's yours well you know i think of a couple classics for me like the mortal combat that, you know, Scorpion, get over here.
并且能把你吸引到机台前。当你想到电子游戏的声音时，你有什么最喜欢的音效吗？我的意思是，我最喜欢的是，以前有一款非常大型的街机游戏叫《Gauntlet》（圣铠传说），它上面有大约四个操纵杆，所以你可以四个人玩不同的角色。其中一个由游戏播报员发出的声音是：精灵严重缺食物（elf needs food badly），精灵严重缺食物，或者精灵快要死了。自从我玩过《Gauntlet》之后，我生活中的每一天， literalmente（字面意思上）只要我一饿，脑子里就会想起“精灵严重缺食物”这句话。每当我想起这个游戏音效……你呢？你的是什么？好吧，你知道的，我想到了几个经典音效，比如《真人快打》（Mortal Kombat）里的，你知道的，蝎子（Scorpion）的“过来吧”（Get over here）。
You know, there was a game I played a lot called Cruising USA that had this kind of ridiculous female passenger voice that was like, yeah, all right, Hollywood, let's go. Oh, wow, Redwoods. Ooh, Hollywood, radical. But one that I think of a lot is the Ryuken, or Shuru Kan, Street Fighter 2 sounds of Raiu or Ken doing the like, Right, you can, sure you can
你知道的，我以前经常玩一款叫《Cruis'n USA》（美国疯狂越野）的游戏，里面有一个非常滑稽的女性乘客声音，听起来就像是：“耶，好吧，好莱坞，我们走吧。”“哦，哇，红杉树。”“噢，好莱坞，太酷了（radical）。”但有一个声音我经常想起，那就是《街头霸王2》（Street Fighter 2）里隆（Ryu）或者肯（Ken）发出的招式语音，类似于：“Hadoken（波动拳）, Shoryuken（升龙拳）……”
Oh, you can That one I just I just say that sometimes to myself Just to make myself happy So clearly, Roman, as audio podcasters, we love sound And we could go on forever Yeah, and the story we have for you today
哦，“Shoryuken”。那个音效，我有时候只是自言自语地说上一遍，就能让自己开心起来。所以很明显，罗曼，作为音频播客制作人，我们热爱声音，而且我们可以滔滔不绝地聊个没完。是的，我们今天带给您的故事，
is all about an iconic video game sound It's about a high-energy vocal performance That helps spawn an entire franchise. The first episode of Hidden Levels is brought to us by 99, MPI contributor James Parkinson. Here it is. Growing up in Michigan, in the 1970s and 80s, Mark Tamal was a wonder boy of video game design. He released a successful game as a teenager and was earning thousands of dollars a month while
正是关于一个标志性的电子游戏音效。它讲述了一段充满高能量的人声表演，正是这段表演催生了一整部游戏系列。《Hidden Levels》的第一集由 99% Invisible 撰稿人詹姆斯·帕金森（James Parkinson）带给我们。故事开始了。马克·特梅尔（Mark Turmel）于 20 世纪 70 和 80 年代在密歇根州长大，是电子游戏设计界的神童。他在十几岁时就发布了一款成功游戏，每个月能赚几千美元，
still living at his parents' house. By the time he was in his 20s, Mark was working full-time as a developer in Chicago, designing coin-operated arcade games. games. Coin-op, back in those days, was always the cutting edge. It was better than any Super Nintendo, better than a Sega Genesis. It was really high-powered. I could put more sprites on the screen, more bullets, more explosions. And so for me, it was like being a kid in a candy store.
当时他仍然住在父母家里。到了二十多岁时，马克已经全职在芝加哥担任开发者，设计投币式街机游戏。投币式街机在那个年代永远都是最尖端的科技。它比任何超级任天堂（Super Nintendo）都要好，比世嘉五代（Sega Genesis）还要好。它的性能非常强大。我可以在屏幕上放置更多的精灵图（sprites）、更多的子弹、更多的爆炸。所以对我来说，这就好像是一个小孩子进了糖果店一样。
The company Mark worked for was called Midway, and they were famous for bringing a number of big Japanese games to the US, like Space Invaders and Pac-Man. and in 1992, they released the iconic fighting game, Mortal Kombat. But Mark was about to take Midway in a very different direction. Mark was a big basketball fan, and in the early 90s, he could tell that the NBA was really having a moment, particularly in Chicago. This was the height of Michael Jordan Mania.
马克工作的公司叫做Midway，他们以将许多大型日本游戏引入美国而闻名，比如《太空侵略者》（Space Invaders）和《吃豆人》（Pac-Man）。在 1992 年，他们发布了标志性的格斗游戏《真人快打》（Mortal Kombat）。但马克即将带领Midway走向一个截然不同的方向。马克是个狂热的篮球迷，在 90 年代初期，他敏锐地察觉到NBA正迎来一个高光时刻，尤其是在芝加哥。这正是迈克尔·乔丹狂热（Michael Jordan Mania）的巅峰时期。
The Chicago Bulls were about to clinch their first championship three-peat, and the popularity of the league was at an all-time high. And Mark Thumel decided he wanted to capture the high-flying, razzle-dazzle energy of professional basketball and put it in an arcade game. He called his new creation NBA Jam. By the fall of 1992, NBA Jam was almost complete, and Mark Tamale and his team decided to test out their new game at an arcade in Chicago called Dennis's Place for Games. They rolled in a 400-pound cabinet, put in the chip with the NBA Jam code, and turned the machine on. Then Mark sat back to watch how the customers in Dennis's Place would react.
芝加哥公牛队即将锁定他们的第一个三连冠王朝，联盟的受欢迎程度达到了历史最高点。马克·特梅尔决定，他要捕捉职业篮球那种飞天遁地、眼花缭乱的能量，并把它放进一款街机游戏里。他将自己的新杰作命名为《NBA Jam》（NBA街头篮球）。到 1992 年秋天，《NBA Jam》几乎制作完成了，马克·特梅尔和他的团队决定在芝加哥一家名为“丹尼斯游戏乐园”（Dennis's Place for Games）的街机厅里测试他们的这款新游戏。他们推进去了一个重达 400 磅的机箱，装入了带有《NBA Jam》代码的芯片，然后打开了机器。接着，马克坐在一旁，观察“丹尼斯游戏乐园”的顾客们会有什么反应。
He says that back then, there was a pretty simple way to gauge whether a Konoop game was going to be successful. You could usually tell in the first couple of hours. In the coin-op business, if you can get somebody to put quarters in, reach into their pocket, go to the cash machine, the change machine, and put money in, you know, that's like really telling. It's very democratic, whether you like it or not. And as Mark watched, the customers at Dennis's place voted with their quarters. They cradded around the NBA jam cabinet, shouting, cursing, fighting for the joystick. It was bedlam.
他说，在当年，要判断一款投币式街机游戏是否会成功，有一个非常简单的方法。通常在前几个小时就能看出来。在投币式街机行业里，如果你能让人把 25 美分硬币投进去，把手伸进口袋，走到收银机、找零机旁把钱投进去，你知道的，那真的说明问题。这非常民主，不管你喜不喜欢。随着马克的观察，丹尼斯游戏乐园的顾客们用他们手里的 25 美分硬币投出了选票。他们挤在《NBA Jam》的机箱周围，大喊大叫、咒骂着、争抢着操纵杆。现场简直一片混乱。
There were fist fights, you know, people gambling. The coin doors were jammed up with money. You know, when somebody would do a big dunk and the backboard would smash into pieces, you know, they'll literally, you know, scream and run around the arcade. You know, it was awesome. I remember exactly how wild this game was. Growing up in Australia, I didn't have access to live NBA games on TV. But NBA Jam was the next best thing.
有打群架的，你知道的，还有人在赌博。投币口都被钱塞满了。你知道的，当有人完成一次精彩的暴扣，篮板被砸得粉碎时，你会听到他们字面意义上地尖叫着在游乐厅里跑来跑去。你知道的，这太棒了。我清楚地记得这款游戏当年有多疯狂。在澳大利亚长大的我，在电视上根本看不了现场直播的 NBA 比赛。但《NBA Jam》就是最棒的替代品。
It quite literally brought the excitement of the NBA to my fingertips. And I think there were a few different elements that drew kids like me in. For one thing, NBA Jam just looked good. It might be hard to believe now, but for kids like me who grew up on games like Pac-Man, NBA Jam was a whole new world. This was the dawn of digitized graphics, which meant that for the first time,
它简直是把 NBA 的激情直接送到了我的指尖。我想，正是几个不同的元素吸引了像我这样的孩子们。首先，《NBA Jam》看起来就很棒。现在可能很难相信，但对于像我这样玩着《吃豆人》之类游戏长大的孩子来说，《NBA Jam》完全是一个新世界。这是数字化图形的黎明，这意味着设计师马克有史以来第一次能够制作出看起来和动起来都像真人一样的虚拟形象。
designers like Mark could make avatars that looked and moved like actual people. You know, we would take videotape and run it through a digitizer that would, you know, create frames and we'd put it on the screen. And it was like, wow, you know, look at that. That's, you know, a photograph right there on my computer screen. At first, Mark recorded video of amateur players he found on local courts throughout Chicago to run through the digitizer. But when he finalized the official licensing deal with the MBA, he did some minor digital surgery. Then we basically chopped the heads off of all of our local athletes and then generated the heads of all of these NBA superstars to, you know, paste on top.
你知道的，我们会把录像带放进数字化仪中，生成帧画面，然后把它放到屏幕上。当时的感觉就像是，哇，你看那个。那就是，你知道的，我电脑屏幕上的一张照片。起初，马克录制了他在芝加哥当地球场上找到的业余球员的视频，然后将这些视频输入数字化仪。但当他与 NBA 完成官方授权协议的最终敲定后，他做了一些微小的数字化“外科手术”。然后我们基本上把所有当地运动员的脑袋砍掉，接着生成所有这些 NBA 超级巨星的脑袋，你知道的，把它们粘贴上去。
Which meant I could play the game as a real-life basketball star, or at least the head of one. I could be Scotty Pippen, Hakeem Elijah won, or Shaquille O'Neal. But the realism ended there, because the gameplay was pure fantasy. At times, NBA Jam felt more like Mortal Kombat than basketball. There were no fouls, no out of bounds, and the players were like superhumans. They left into the rafters for sky-high dunks and shot impossibly long-range three-pointed. When a player made three baskets in a row, the ball burst into flames and he became unstoppable
这意味着我可以在游戏中扮演现实生活中的篮球明星，或者至少是他们的头像。我可以成为斯科蒂·皮蓬（Scottie Pippen）、哈基姆·奥拉朱旺（Hakeem Olajuwon）或沙奎尔·奥尼尔（Shaquille O'Neal）。但现实主义也仅限于此了，因为游戏的玩法纯粹是幻想。有时，《NBA Jam》与其说是篮球，倒不如说更像《真人快打》。这里没有犯规，没有出界，球员们就像是超人一样。他们高高跃起冲向篮筐完成超高空扣篮，还能投出远得不可思议的超远三分球。当一名球员连续投进三个球时，篮球就会燃起熊熊烈火，在接下来的几次进攻中，他将变得势不可挡。
for the next several possessions. But I think there was one element in particular that made NBA jams stand out from all the other games in the arcade. It was an iconic sound that cut through all the bleeps and bloops and drew people to the NBA, jam cabinet like moths to a flame. Even if you didn't play the game growing up, you might have heard this sound. From downtown, launches a shot, he's a fire! I'm talking about the voice of the game's announcer.
但我认为其中有一个元素让《NBA Jam》在游乐厅的所有其他游戏中脱颖而出。那是一个标志性的声音，它切断了所有的电子哔哔声，像飞蛾扑火一样把人们吸引到《NBA Jam》的机箱前。即使你小时候没玩过这款游戏，你也可能听过这个声音。From downtown... Launches a shot... He's on fire! 我说的是游戏播报员的声音。
Today, voice acting is a key component of most video game productions. But back in the 1970s, there were no voices in video games at all. High-quality audio recordings were just too large to fit on the sound chips of arcade machines. The earliest voices heard in video games were digitised, using a technique called speech synthesis. Basically combining short sounds or syllables to form complete words. These synthesised voices were a clever solution to the problem, but they didn't exactly sound realistic. The space-themed shooter Stratovox was the first game to attempt this. As you find at Alien Ships, a very unnatural sounding narrator would shout a handful of distorted phrases.
如今，配音已经是大多数电子游戏制作中的关键组成部分。但在 20 世纪 70 年代，电子游戏中根本没有声音。高品质的音频录音体积太大了，根本无法塞进街机机器的音效芯片里。电子游戏中听到的最早的声音是经过数字化的，使用的是一种叫做语音合成（speech synthesis）的技术。基本上就是把简短的声音或音节组合起来形成完整的单词。这些合成声音是解决问题的一个巧妙方案，但它们听起来确实不太逼真。太空主题射击游戏《Stratovox》（星际声波）是第一款尝试这样做的游戏。当你迎战外星飞船时，一个听起来非常不自然的解说员会大喊出一些扭曲短语。
Believe it or not, the narrator there was saying lucky and very good. One of the first games to use true recorded voiceover was Dragon's Lair in 1983. They managed to do this using laser disc technology. The team didn't have the budget to hire actors, so much of the voice acting was done by the animators and the production staff. Please save me. The cage is locked with a key. The dragon keeps it around his neck.
信不信由你，那里的解说员当时说的是“幸运”（lucky）和“非常好”（very good）。最早使用真实录制配音的游戏之一是 1983 年的《Dragon's Lair》（龙穴历险记）。他们利用激光影碟（laser disc）技术做到了这一点。当时团队没有预算去聘请演员，所以大部分配音都是由动画师和制作人员完成的。请救救我。笼子被一把锁锁上了。恶龙把它挂在脖子上。
Improvements in computer chip technology allowed for increased memory, and by the early 90s, it was common for arcade games to use real voice recordings, at least very short ones. These companies still weren't hiring professional actors, though. As a result, the voice performances were often bad, like, really, really bad. You must recover all the energy immediately, Mega Man. But where is Dr. Wiley? That's a good question. Just one more page, and I would have finished this book.
计算机芯片技术的进步使得内存不断增加。到 90 年代初，街机游戏使用真实的语音录音已经很常见了，至少是非常短的录音。不过，这些公司仍然没有聘请专业演员。结果就是，配音的表现往往很烂，我是说，真的、真的很烂。你必须立即恢复所有的能量，洛克人（Mega Man）。但是威利博士在哪里？是个好问题。只要再翻一页，我就能读完这本书了。
Die, monster. You don't belong in this world. Captain Wesker, where's Chris? Stop it. Don't open that door. Yeah, that wasn't going to cut it for NBA. Jam. This new basketball game was going to need a voice that could match the high-octane style of the gameplay and cut through the noisy commotion of an arcade to draw people in. Someone with a distinctive delivery that would keep people dipping into their pockets for more quarters. They needed
死吧，怪物。你不属于这个世界。韦斯克队长（Captain Wesker），克里斯（Chris）在哪里？住手。别打开那扇门。是的，这在《NBA Jam》里可吃不开。这款全新的篮球游戏需要一种声音，既能匹配游戏高辛烷值的风格，又能穿透游乐厅里嘈杂的喧闹声把人们吸引过来。需要一个具有独特嗓音的人，能让人们不断把手伸进口袋掏出更多的硬币。他们需要
this guy. So firstly, can I just get you to introduce yourself, please. Hi everyone, Tim Kittzer from NBA Jam, Boom Shackalaka. That was very loud. Tim Kitzrow was not a famous actor back in the early 90s and he certainly didn't grow up with dreams of becoming a voice actor for an iconic video game. But he'd always been a showman. He was one of seven children and he was the entertainer in the family. He says his goal at dinner was to get milk to come out of someone's nose.
这个人。那么首先，能请你做个自我介绍吗？大家好，我是《NBA Jam》的蒂姆·基特罗（Tim Kitzrow），Boom Shakalaka！声音真大。蒂姆·基特罗在 90 年代初并不是什么大明星，他当然也没有从小梦想成为某个标志性电子游戏的配音演员。但他一直是个极具表演天赋的人。他是七个孩子中的老七，也是家族里的开心果。他说他晚饭时的目标就是把牛奶从某人的鼻子眼里呛出来。
One of my heroes is Mel Blanc, the man of a thousand voices, Looney Tunes. So, you know, when I was younger, I often did cartoon voices like underdog. You know, the Simon Meyer Senator says underdog must die, or droopy, droopy dog. There's a telephone, butch, it's a dame. What did she say, butch? She's so unselfish. Tim got into theatre in high school and went on to study acting at Purchase College, where he crossed paths with some heavy hitters.
我的偶像之一是梅尔·布兰克（Mel Blanc），那个拥有千面嗓音的男人，《乐一通》（Looney Tunes）的配音。所以，你知道的，我年轻的时候经常模仿卡通声音，比如底特律小超人（Underdog）。你知道的，西蒙·梅尔参议员说“小超人必须死”，或者忧郁狗（Droopy）。这儿有电话，巴奇（Butch），是个妞。她说了什么，巴奇？她太无私了。蒂姆在高中时加入了戏剧社，后来去帕切斯学院（Purchase College）学习表演，在那里他与一些大人物擦出了火花。
My roommate was Stan Tucci, Vin Reims, was in the, so a lot of big names came out of that place. But Tim's career didn't tell him. take off quite like those two. He spent the 80s as a genuine actor bouncing between cities like New York and L.A. looking for work. And eventually, he wound up in Chicago. He trained with the comedians at Second City while auditioning for commercials and playing the drums in a local band. His career felt like it was stuttering, until it took a very unlikely turn. Of course, the way the world works, sometimes, you know, you have one plan and then it goes another way.
我的室友是斯坦·图齐（Stan Tucci）、文·瑞姆斯（Ving Rhames）也在那儿，所以那个地方走出了很多大人物。但蒂姆的职业生涯并没有像那两位那样一飞冲天。他在 80 年代作为一个真正的演员，在纽约和洛杉矶等城市之间辗转寻觅工作。最终，他落脚在芝加哥。他跟着“第二城”（Second City）的喜剧演员们一起训练，同时为商业广告试镜，并在当地的一支乐队里打鼓。他的职业生涯感觉就像是在磕磕绊绊地停滞不前，直到它迎来了一个极其戏剧性的转折。当然，世界的运作方式往往就是这样，有时候，你知道的，你有一个计划，然后事情却走向了另一个方向。
It all started because a couple of Tim's bandmates worked in Midway's pinball division. They often needed people to record little bits of voiceover, and they knew that their drummer Tim was pretty good at impressions. One day, they asked him to help out with a Gilligan's Island pinball game. So I was hired to do Mr. Howell from Gilligan's Island. Maybe I can buy a new dinghy for my yacht. Over time, Tim became a regular voice on Midway's Pinball game. games. I did the Twilight Zone, attack from Mars.
这一切都开始于蒂姆的几个乐队成员在Midway的弹珠机部门工作。他们经常需要有人录制一小段旁白，而且他们知道他们的鼓手蒂姆很擅长模仿。有一天，他们请他帮忙为一个《吉利根岛》（Gilligan's Island）主题的弹珠机配音。所以我被雇来扮演《吉利根岛》里的霍维尔先生（Mr. Howell）。也许我可以为我的游艇买一艘新丁船。随着时间推移，蒂姆成了Midway弹珠机游戏的常驻配音。我做过《阴阳魔界》（Twilight Zone）、《火星人袭击》（Attack from Mars）。
This is an emergency broadcast. The Earth is being invaded by flying saucers from Mars. The Shadow, World Cup soccer, NBA pinball, you know, or fast break, whatever. It was just going and having fun and actually this time I was getting paid for it. Being a voice actor for pinball was a fun side gig, but not much more than that. Tim never felt like it had the potential to be an actual career. I really had no idea what I was doing, you know, getting into that business. I knew that I loved playing pinball, but pinball, as I said, 15 games later, you know, I still didn't know much about the industry, still couldn't play worth a lick. It was just a fun, extra gig for extra money, extra beer money. Meanwhile, Mark Tamal and the NBA jam crew were putting the finishing
这是一个紧急广播。地球正遭到来自火星的飞碟入侵。《The Shadow》（魅影）、《世界杯足球赛》（World Cup Soccer）、《NBA Pinball》，你知道的，或者还有《Fast Break》等等。这一切就是去玩得开心，而且这一次我还能因此拿到报酬。成为弹珠机的配音演员是一份有趣的外快工作，但也仅此而已。蒂姆从不觉得这有潜力成为一项真正的事业。我真的不知道自己在做什么，你知道的，就这么一头扎进了那个行业。我知道我喜欢玩弹珠机，但弹珠机，就像我说的，15 款游戏做下来，你知道的，我对这个行业仍然知之甚少，技术依然烂得不行。这只是一份为了赚点外快、赚点买啤酒钱的有趣兼职。与此同时，马克·特梅尔和《NBA Jam》团队正在为他们全新的篮球游戏做最后精修。
touches on their brand new basketball game. They'd signed the licensing deal with the NBA and figured out the gameplay and the graphics. And at a certain point, they started to think about the sound. A guy named John Hay handled just about every aspect of the audio for NBA Jam. He wrote the game's deeply 90s soundtrack. And in order to make the game sound more wife-like, he went out and recorded all these basketball sounds in the wild, like balls being dribbled or sneaker squeaks on hardwood floors. But Mark Tamal and John Hay knew that one of the most important sonic elements was the voice of the game's announcer. They wanted a commentator who would make the game come alive and sound like the way the NBA sounded on TV. Mark even thought about hiring an actual
他们已经与 NBA 签署了授权协议，并弄好了游戏玩法和图形。在某个阶段，他们开始考虑声音的问题。一个名叫约翰·海（John Hay）的人几乎包办了《NBA Jam》音频的所有方面。他创作了这款游戏极具 90 年代风格的配音原声带。为了让游戏听起来更有生活气息，他特意跑到户外，录制了各种真实的篮球声音，比如运球声或者运动鞋在地板上的摩擦声。但马克·特梅尔和约翰·海都知道，最重要的声音元素之一就是游戏解说员的声音。他们想要一个让游戏活过来、听起来就像电视里的 NBA 一样的解说员。马克甚至考虑过雇一个真正的
NBA commentator, but they didn't have the budget. Luckily for them, an affordable alternative was kicking around the office, drinking beer with the pinball guys. I used to just get regular calls because every couple months there was a new pinball game, and it's like, let's go to Tim. And so this felt no different to me. The recording studio was located in Midway's Pinball Factory. It was a giant, noisy space with lots of workers and hundreds of pinball machines.
NBA 解说员，但他们没有预算。对他们来说幸运的是，办公室里正好有一个便宜的替代人选，他正和那帮玩弹珠机的家伙们一起喝啤酒呢。我以前经常接到常规电话，因为每隔几个月就会有一款新的弹珠机游戏，然后他们就会说：“去找蒂姆吧。”所以这对我来说感觉没什么不同。录音室位于Midway的弹珠机工厂里。那是一个巨大、嘈杂的空间，有很多工人和几百台弹珠机。
But all the way in the back, there was a little five-foot-by-five-foot vocal booth. They called it the meat locker. It was kind of a depressing little place, but it was cozy. It was like our little world. It was just the sound guys, you know, not much bigger than a household giant refrigerators. and a little window from you to see John.
但在最里头，有一个小小的五英尺见方的录音室。他们把它叫做“冷库”（meat locker）。那是一个有点压抑的小地方，但很温馨。就像是我们自己的小世界。里面只有音效制作人员，你知道的，比家用的大冰箱大不了多少。通过一个小窗户，你可以看到约翰。
So, yeah, although it was kind of dingy and dark and small and everything else, it was home, and, you know, it's where some of the best work was ever done. Mark and John worked to brainstorm a library of words and phrases they needed Tim to record. First, they needed the names of every player in the game and a few different takes for each so that it wouldn't sound repetitive. Then they started compiling a list of all the different things that happened in a basketball game that Tim was going to need to react to. Just like a TV announcer, he needed to say something every time there was a big dunk or a three-pointer or a block shot. John Hay wrote lines for each
所以，是的，尽管它又破旧、又黑暗、又狭小，但那就是我们的家，而且，你知道的，一些最棒的作品就是在那里完成的。马克和约翰开始集思广益，列出一堆他们需要蒂姆录制的词汇和短语库。首先，他们需要游戏中每个球员的名字，并且每个名字都要录制好几个不同的版本，这样听起来才不会显得重复。接着，他们开始列出一张清单，上面写满了篮球比赛中可能发生的各种情况，蒂姆需要对这些情况做出反应。就像电视解说员一样，每当有精彩扣篮、三分球或盖帽时，他都必须说点什么。约翰·海为每个类别都写了台词，
category, some of them taken directly from NBA broadcasts. When Tim Kitzrow finally got into the booth, he decided he wanted to model his delivery off a veteran NBA announcer Marve Albert. Albert was the most famous basketball commentator in the world at the time, and he had a flamboyant, energetic style. Oh, a spectacular move by Michael Short. That's 13. You know, jump-off point was realizing that to me, Mar Valbert, compared to other sports broadcasters, he brought that extra energy.
其中一些直接取自 NBA 的现场转播。当蒂姆·基特罗终于走进录音室时，他决定以一位资深 NBA 解说员马夫·阿尔伯特（Marv Albert）为原型来设计自己的解说风格。阿尔伯特是当时世界上最著名的篮球解说员，他拥有华丽、充满活力的风格。哦！迈克尔·乔丹的一次精彩绝伦的动作！比分是 13 比……你知道的，切入点是意识到在我看来，与其他体育广播员相比，马夫·阿尔伯特带来了那种额外的能量。
And I knew that I wanted to emulate that. But Tim was going to be Mar Valbert turned up to 11. Mar Valbert with a splash of Mortal Kombat. To get in the right headspace, Tim would vote. visualize high-flying dunks and channel that energy into his performance. So that's where I kind of got that timber, that tone that, you know, that NBA Jam had based off of like what I heard and then just making it my own. Rejected! He's hitting up. He's on fire!
我知道我想要模仿这种风格。但蒂姆将是一个把音量开到 11 档的马夫·阿尔伯特。一个融合了《真人快打》风格的马夫·阿尔伯特。为了进入正确的状态，蒂姆会想象那些飞天遁地的暴扣，并将这种能量注入到他的表演中。所以这就是我如何获得那种音色、那种音调的地方，你知道的，《NBA Jam》正是基于我所听到的声音，然后融入了我自己的特色。Rejected（被拒绝/帽掉）！他正在热头上（He's heating up）！他着火了（He's on fire）！
Well, I mean, Tim's, I mean, he's amazing. He's a genius. This is Mark Timel again. He says that Tim didn't stick to the script. Right away, he started getting creative. He's so quick-witted, you know, he's always willing to, you know, iterate and improve and take feedback. And when Tim went into the studio, he would just ad lib. And it was magic, you know, immediately. But Tim had to improvise within constraints. The arcade machines at the time still didn't have a lot of memory, so his catchphrases needed to be short. Like half a center, Or even
好吧，我的意思是，蒂姆，我的意思是，他太棒了。他是个天才。这是马克·特梅尔再次评价。他说蒂姆并没有死守剧本。一上来，他就开始发挥创意。他脑子转得太快了，你知道的，他总是乐于去迭代、改进并接受反馈。当蒂姆走进录音室时，他会直接即兴发挥。那简直是魔术，你知道的，立竿见影。但蒂姆必须在限制条件内进行即兴创作。当时的街机内存依然不大，所以他的口头禅必须简短。比如“半个中锋”（Half a center），或者甚至
even just a single word As for the game's most famous catchphrase Tim doesn't take credit The exact origin story is a little murky But Tim believes it was a suggestion by John Carlton One of the game's artists He'd been listening to the funk group Sly and the Family Stone.
仅仅是一个单独的词。至于游戏中那句最著名的口头禅，蒂姆可不敢居功。确切的起源故事有点扑朔迷离。但蒂姆相信那是游戏美工之一约翰·卡尔顿（John Carlton）的建议。他当时一直在听放克乐队“斯莱和斯通家族”（Sly and the Family Stone）的歌。
And on the song, I want to take you higher, there's a chorus where they sing. Boo shaka, laca, laca, laca, booshaka, laca, laca, bow' down. I want to take you high. But they were just like, boo shakalaka,
在这首歌《I want to take you higher》中，有一个副歌他们在唱：Boo shaka, laca, laca, laca, booshaka, laca, laca, bow down. I want to take you higher. 但他们当时唱的其实是，boo shaka laca，
they weren't saying boom shakalaka they were saying boom shakalaka laika. They were saying boo shaka laca laca, booshaka, booshak, whatever. Actually, the song goes boom laika laika. But you get the point. So he just said, Hey John, tell Tim to say boom shocklaka. Once again, this is the story that I heard. I'm there, but I don't remember it. But I do remember vaguely, John just saying to me, say boom shocklaka. And I just said, what does that mean? I don't know, just say it. And I went, boom shockalaka. And I said, is that? And he goes, yeah, do a couple more. Boom shockalaka. Yeah, that's probably good. All right, moving on.
他们唱的不是 boom shakalaka，他们唱的是 boom shakalaka laika。他们唱的是 boo shaka laca laca, booshaka, booshak 之类的。其实歌词是 boom laika laika。但你懂我的意思。所以他只是说：“嘿，约翰，告诉蒂姆说 boom shakakalaka。”再次声明，这是我听来的故事。我在现场，但我记不清了。但我隐约记得约翰只是对我说：“说 boom shakakalaka。”我就问：“那是什么意思？”“不知道，说就行了。”然后我就说了：“Boom shakakalaka！”接着我问：“这样行吗？”他回道：“行，再来几个。”“Boom shakakalaka！”“对，那个大概不错。好了，下一个。”
in around 20 hours. And when Tim was finished, he didn't think it was a big deal at all. As far as he was concerned, this was just another gig. Like Gilligan's Island Pinball, little did he know that those 20 hours would change the course of his life. And from that point forward, he'd be known to the world as Mr. Boom Shakalaka. After the success of their test night at Dennis's place for games, the NBA Jam team was confident that their game was not a dud. But still, Mark Tim, had this lingering worry that the game wouldn't translate outside of Chicago. After all, he could see the back-end data,
总共花了大约 20 个小时。当蒂姆录完之后，他根本没把这当回事。在他看来，这不过又是一份零工而已。就像《吉利根岛》弹珠机一样，他当时做梦也没想到，那 20 个小时会改变他人生的轨迹。从那一刻起，他将以“Boom Shakalaka 先生”的名义闻名于世。在丹尼斯游戏乐园的测试之夜取得成功后，《NBA Jam》团队确信他们的游戏绝不是个半吊子。不过，马克·特梅尔心里仍然隐隐有些担忧，担心这款游戏在芝加哥以外的地方水土不服。毕竟，他能看到后台数据，
showing which NBA teams people were choosing to play with. So I knew looking at the stats that the bulls were just dominant. Everybody was picking the balls. And so in the back of my head, I thought, maybe this is a Chicago thing. When the game went live across the country, Mark flew to L.A. to see how it played there. He went to an arcade in Westwood, where NBA Jam had just been installed.
显示人们在选择使用哪个 NBA 球队。所以通过查看统计数据，我知道公牛队简直统治了一切。每个人都在选公牛队。所以在我的潜意识里，我心想，也许这只是芝加哥当地的现象。当这款游戏在全国各地正式上线时，马克飞往洛杉矶去看看那里的反响。他走进韦斯特伍德（Westwood）的一家刚安装了《NBA Jam》的游乐厅。
And I walked in and I just watched. And it was the same bedlam that I had seen in Chicago, except that the players were picking the Lakers. And so it really was that moment where I said to myself, wow, you know, this is going to happen in every NBA city at the very least. And this is going to happen around the country. And sure enough, that's exactly, you know, what happened. NBA Jam was picked up by arcades all around the country, and city after city,
我走进去，站在一旁静静地看着。那场面跟我之前在芝加哥看到的一模一样，唯一的区别是那里的玩家都在选湖人队。所以那一刻我对自己说：“哇，你知道的，这至少会在每一个 NBA 城市上演。这将在全国各地发生。”果不其然，事情就是这样发生的。《NBA Jam》被全美各地的游乐厅疯狂引进，一个接一个的城市里，
people happily forked out their hard-end quarters in order to rain down three-pointers with Detloft Shremf, while dunked from half-court with Clyde Drexler. If there was one group of people who seemed to love the game most of all, it was NBA players. On his days off, Miami Heatstar Glenn Rice would wait in line at the local arcade just to play NBA Jam as himself. Gary Payton, a point guard with the Seattle Supersonics, demanded to know why he hadn't been included in the game. He even sent personal photos to Mark Demal that he could use to make Peyton's avatar. And then there was Shaquille O'Neill.
人们高高兴兴地掏出他们辛苦赚来的 25 美分硬币，只为了用德特勒夫·施伦夫（Detlef Schremf）投出漫天三分雨，或者用克莱德·德雷克斯勒（Clyde Drexler）从半场起跳完成暴扣。如果说有一群人似乎对这款游戏爱不释手，那就是 NBA 球员们。在休息日，迈阿密热火队的球星格伦·莱斯（Glenn Rice）会排队等候在当地的游乐厅里，只为了能在《NBA Jam》里扮演他自己。西雅图超音速队的控球后卫加里·佩顿（Gary Payton）质问为什么游戏里没有他。他甚至给马克·特梅尔寄去了个人照片，好让他用来制作佩顿的虚拟形象。然后就是沙奎尔·奥尼尔。
We got contacted from the distributor in Orlando and said that Shaq wanted to buy two games. Shaq wanted one NBA jam machine for his own house and another for the Orlando Magic's team jet. They brought one of the NBA Jam cabinets onto the jet and it traveled with them on the road and they would reel it up into Shaq's hotel suite. And the players, instead of going out and partying or clubbing, they would go in and just play and play as each other. Even the opposing team would come in the night before the game or after the game and play. In 1993, NBA Jam was the talk of both the arcade world and the world of professional basketball. But back in Chicago, Tim Kitzroi still hadn't played the game.
我们接到奥兰多经销商的联系，说奥尼尔想买两台游戏机。奥尼尔想要一台《NBA Jam》机器放在自己家里，另一台放在奥兰多魔术队的球队专机上。他们把其中一台《NBA Jam》机箱搬上了专机，随着球队四处征战，他们还会把它搬进奥尼尔的酒店套房里。球员们不去外面聚会或泡夜店，而是聚在一起，一遍又一遍地玩，在游戏里扮演彼此。甚至连对手球队也会在比赛前夜或比赛结束后跑来玩。1993 年，《NBA Jam》成为了街机世界和职业篮球世界津津乐道的话题。但在芝加哥，蒂姆·基特罗甚至还没玩过这款游戏。
So I asked John to say, hey, where could I, you know, go see, you know, NBA Jam? Tim went to a nearby arcade and walked up to a cabinet that he assumed was NBA Jam. But it turns out it was a different basketball game, one of their competitors. And Tim was not all that impressed by the announcer. It would be like, nice shot, four two. He makes it. I was like, what the hell is wrong with that guy? And I walk over, he watched the NBA Jam,
于是我问约翰：“嘿，我去哪里能玩到、看到《NBA Jam》呢？”蒂姆走到附近的一家游乐厅，径直走向一台他以为是《NBA Jam》的机器。但结果证明那是另一款篮球游戏，他们的竞争对手的游戏。而且蒂姆对那个解说员的水平并不是很满意。那声音大概是：“好球，得两分。他投进了。”我当时想：“那家伙到底是怎么回事？”然后我走过去，看《NBA Jam》，
he's on fire from downtown, not tonight, you know, whatever. And I was like, well, that guy's pretty good. And it was clear that the kids in the arcade agreed with him. They were absolutely loving NBA Jam. And that was like, you know, this moment. I went, wow, this is something. This is like, you know, made the equivalent of being, you know, someone from, like, you know, a group that hears their song on the radio for the first
“He's on fire！”“From downtown！”“Not tonight！”你知道的，诸如此类。我心想：“嗯，那家伙挺不错的。”很显然，游乐厅里的孩子们也同意他的看法。他们绝对是爱死《NBA Jam》了。那一刻的感觉就像是，我心想：“哇，这可真了不得。这感觉就相当于，你知道的，某个乐队第一次在广播里听到自己的歌一样。”
time. It's like, this is a hit. And I got kind of charged, but I couldn't resist sometimes just by accident, didn't think about it, but I'm watching. And I would start to say, like, rejected, ugly shot, get that stuff out of here. Boom, shock a lot. You know, someone turned around like, hey, man, you sound like the dude in the game. I go, dude, I am the dude. And then it is, it is you. NBA Jam went on to become a bigger hit than anyone ever expected. To use an arcade term, it was a quarter muncher, devouring coins like a hungry hippo. In its first year, NBA Jam made $1 billion in revenue, one quarter at a time.
心想：“这绝对是一首热单。”我当时有点兴奋，但有时候我情不自禁，纯粹是偶然，没多想，就在一旁看着。然后我开始下意识地喊出来：“Rejected！Ugly shot！Get that stuff out of here！Boom, shakakalaka！”你知道的，有人转过身来问：“嘿，哥们儿，你听起来跟游戏里的那个老兄一模一样。”我回答：“老兄，我就是那个老兄。”“真的？真的是你吗？”《NBA Jam》最终成为了比任何人预期中都要轰动的超级大热门。用街机行业的术语来说，它就是个“吃币怪兽”（quarter muncher），像一头饥饿的河马一样疯狂吞噬着硬币。在推出的第一年里，《NBA Jam》创造了 10 亿美元的收入，全都是靠一枚枚 25 美分硬币积少成多攒起来的。
I was out at Midway in their lunchroom, and there was an article on the board, you know, just like a Xerox article that said, NBA Jam surpasses, breaks all records, makes a billion dollars in quarters first year. And I just said, who wrote this? This is funny. I just absolutely convinced it was someone just having, you know, some fun to kind of like prop up the team and, you know, give them some confidence like, yeah, NBA Jam's a great game, but had no idea in reality the game made a billion dollars. And that was the moment my brain went, wait a minute, I made 900. What? It's impossible to say whether or not the game would have been successful without Tim Kitzero, but his contribution is undeniable. In 1994, a version of NBA Jam was released for the Super Nintendo. At that time, home consoles had a lot less memory than arcade cabinets,
我当时在 Midway 的员工餐厅里，布告栏上贴着一篇文章，你知道的，就是那种复印的 Xerox 文章，上面写着：《NBA Jam》超越并打破所有纪录，第一年狂揽 10 亿美元硬币。我当时就说：“这是谁写的？太逗了。”我绝对坚信这只是某人为团队加油鼓劲、树立信心而开的一个玩笑，就好比说“耶，《NBA Jam》是个好游戏”，但现实中根本不可能知道这款游戏赚了 10 亿美元。就在那个瞬间，我的大脑当机了：“等等，我拿到的报酬是 900 块？什么鬼？”很难说如果没有蒂姆·基特罗，这款游戏是否还能取得成功，但他的贡献是不可磨灭的。1994 年，《NBA Jam》推出了超级任天堂（Super Nintendo）版本。当时，家用主机的内存比街机机箱小得多，
and so certain elements had to be stripped from the game to make it small enough to fit on a cartridge. In the end, they cut the music, but retained the sound effects and Tim Kittrow's iconic voice. As new versions of the game got released, Tim was able to renegotiate for better compensation. And while NBA jam didn't make him rich, the game changed the course of his career
因此必须从游戏中剥离某些元素，才能让它变得足够小，从而塞进卡带里。最终，他们砍掉了音乐，但保留了音效和蒂姆·基特罗标志性的声音。随着游戏新版本的发布，蒂姆得以重新谈判以获得更好的报酬。虽然《NBA Jam》并没有让他暴富，但这款游戏改变了他的职业生涯轨迹，
and his whole approach to video game voice work. It went from this side gig he did for beer money to a viable career. I wasn't going into a room of 20 people who looked like me to do a Bud Light beer commercial or a cheesy sitcom, you know, audition or an extra part in a movie. This was people saying, we want Tim because Tim delivers the goods.
以及他对电子游戏配音的整个态度。它从一份为了赚点买啤酒钱的兼职，变成了一项可行且长远的事业。我再也不用走进一个挤满了 20 个长相跟我差不多的演员的房间去为一个百威淡啤广告试镜，或者去试镜那些烂俗的的情景喜剧，你知道的，或者在电影里演个龙套角色。这是人们在说：“我们要蒂姆，因为蒂姆能交出完美的货色。”
Off the back of NBA jam, Tim became the voice of other Midway sports titles, like NFL Blitz. NHL hits. Welcome to Boston. The cats are two front teeth and let's do this. And MLB's lugfest. And now sit back.
借助《NBA Jam》的东风，蒂姆成为了Midway其他体育游戏作品的御用配音，比如《NFL Blitz》。《NHL HITS》。欢迎来到波士顿。猫掉了两颗前牙，我们开始吧！还有 MLB 的《Slugfest》（疯狂棒球）。现在，请靠后坐好。
It's time to play ball. By this stage, the technology had improved to the point where there were really no limits on how much voiceover you could include in video games. And with the freedom to get as wild as he wanted, Tim delivered some truly outrageous baseball banter. Hey, here's one, Jimmy.
是时候开球了。到了这个阶段，技术已经发展到了一定程度，电子游戏中可以包含多少语音旁白已经完全没有限制了。在拥有了可以尽情狂野的自由后，蒂姆贡献了一些真正离谱的棒球俏皮话。嘿，听着这个，吉米。
Famous people did her alive, all-star team. On the mound, I got Abe Lincoln. Why? Abe Lincoln, he's got these beady eyes, got a little drifter beard, he's intimidated. Who do you got? With Slugfest, I wrote, you know, all the creative color commentary. So that was actually the most exciting part of my career.
名人死后复活全明星阵容。在投手丘上，我选了亚伯拉罕·林肯。为什么？亚伯拉罕·林肯，他有一双小眼睛，留着一点流浪汉式的胡子，他很有威慑力。你选谁？在制作《Slugfest》时，我自己写了所有的创意色彩解说。所以这其实是我职业生涯中最激动人心的部分。
I was not only making really good money, I was writing and basically in charge of the content. So I was given the opportunity to basically create the whole world. Tim Kitsrow is not the most important voice actor in video game history, but his performance at NBA Jam is certainly one of the most beloved, and his role in the game's success set an important precedent for how voice acting can elevate a video game and bring it to life. In the decades that followed, game developers began to invest more and more in vocal performances, and sports game companies started spending money to hire real-life announcers to do commentary.
我不仅赚到了非常可观的收入，而且我还参与了剧本创作，基本上掌控了内容。所以我得到了一个机会，基本上可以创造整个世界。蒂姆·基特罗并不是电子游戏史上最重要的配音演员，但他在《NBA Jam》中的表演绝对是最受喜爱的表演之一，他在游戏成功中所扮演的角色，为配音如何提升电子游戏并赋予其生命力开创了一个重要的先例。在随后的几十年里，游戏开发者开始在人声表演上投入越来越多的资金，体育游戏公司也开始花钱聘请现实生活中的解说员来做实况解说。
In fact, one of the most famous video game franchises of all time is named after an announcer. Welcome to Madden NFL 2000, the new millennium of football. And Tim's influence wasn't limited to video games. it fed back into the sport of basketball itself. Over time, NBA Jam catchphrases like he's heating up have become part of the general basketball vernacular. And if you turn on a game today, it's pretty obvious that many basketball commentators grew up playing NBA Jan.
事实上，史上最著名的电子游戏系列之一就是以一位解说员的名字命名的。欢迎来到《Madden NFL 2000》，美式橄榄球的新千禧年。而且蒂姆的影响力并不仅限于电子游戏。它反哺到了篮球这项运动本身。随着时间的推移，像“He's heating up”这样的《NBA Jam》口头禅已经成为了日常篮球俚语的一部分。如果你今天打开一场比赛，你会发现很明显，许多篮球解说员都是玩着《NBA Jam》长大的。
Crosses over, finds Zubats, gives it up to harder at the frito line. A lot of Zubats! Boom! Shakalaka! As he dumps it with two hands, and the Clippers lead 17-7. Oh my goodness, feeling like NBA Jam here early. All-jones, locked into the ramp. Gabs, right, blue, left. The back to paint, leaves it out for the cutting Boston. He'll dump it over the top of Lopton, Brandon Boston.
变向过人，找到了祖巴茨（Zubats），传给了罚球线附近的哈登。大批的祖巴茨！Boom！Shakalaka！他双手暴扣得分，快船队以 17 比 7 领先。哦天哪，早期感觉就像在玩《NBA Jam》一样。琼斯（Jones），锁死斜坡。Gabs，右边，蓝色，左边。传回内线，分球给切入的波士顿（Boston）。他从洛普顿（Lopton）头顶上把球传过去，布兰登·波士顿（Brandon Boston）。
Boom, Shakalaka! Boom, Shakalaka! Yeah! Boom, Sakka! Yeah! Boom, Sakka! Whoa! Boa!
The rebound! Apple buzzer! The rebound! Whiff! Whiff! Whitch! Whip! Whip!
篮板！压哨！篮板！挥空！挥空！挥！挥！
Apple buzzer. It's good. We are back with Hidden Levels in our first episode, Roman Mars. Ben Brock Johnson. We have been talking NBA Jam, and the vocal performance is really just one of the most distinct things about the game, because NBA Jam has all these other quirks. and these quirks really make this game legendary. It has so many hidden design details, exactly the kind of stuff we're talking about in this series. Let's talk about a few of these hidden design details. You game? Absolutely. All right. So James Parkinson in the story, he talked about how the game wasn't the most realistic depiction of basketball, even though
压哨球。球进了。欢迎回到《Hidden Levels》的第一集，我是罗曼·马尔斯。我是本·布洛克·约翰逊。我们一直在聊《NBA Jam》，而人声表演真的是这款游戏最独特的特色之一，因为《NBA Jam》还有许多其他奇特的恶趣味。而正是这些奇特的恶趣味让这款游戏真正成为了传奇。它有着如此多的隐藏设计细节，这正是我们在本系列中要讨论的内容。让我们来聊聊其中几个隐藏的设计细节。你准备好了吗？当然。好的。詹姆斯·帕金森在故事中提到，尽管游戏使用了这种新技术来捕捉真人，但它并不是对篮球最写实的描绘，也许算不上超级逼真。
they were using this new technology to capture people, maybe not super realistic. Sure. I mean, the ball caught fire. So that rarely happens in a basketball game. But, yeah, I get you. Right. So if you knew where to look in this game, you could also unlock secret players who were not athletes, at least that I know of.
当然。我是说，篮球都着火了。这在篮球比赛中可是极其罕见的。不过，是的，我明白你的意思。所以，如果你知道在这款游戏里去哪里寻找，你还可以解锁一些并非运动员的秘密角色，至少据我所知是这样的。
So Bill Clinton is one example. Al Gore is another. Oh, I had no idea. What other examples are there? George Clinton could also be unlocked as a character. All the Clintons are represented. All the Clintons, man. George Clinton.
比尔·克林顿就是一个例子。戈尔是另一个。哦，我完全不知道。还有哪些其他例子？乔治·克林顿（George Clinton）也可以被解锁为角色。所有的克林顿都被涵盖了。所有的克林顿，天哪。乔治·克林顿。
That's right. And he was a character named P-Funk. That was in the tournament edition of the game. You could also access one of the people who we heard from in the episode who made NBA Jam. We don't think of programmers as ballers necessarily, but all the programmers were playable in the game, and that includes Mark Termel, who we heard from earlier. Was he particularly good at the game as a player? It may shock you to learn that he was practically unstoppable.
没错。他是一个名叫 P-Funk 的角色。那是游戏的锦标赛版本（tournament edition）里的内容。你还可以访问我们在本集中听到的制作《NBA Jam》的人之一。我们通常不会把程序员视为球星，但在游戏中所有程序员都是可玩的，这其中就包括我们前面听到过的马克·特梅尔。作为一名玩家，他在游戏里特别厉害吗？说出来可能会让你大吃一惊，他简直是势不可挡。
I mean, you know, that's what I would do. same that's awesome here's another uh interesting sort of secret uh easter egg in the game roman it's called super clean floors which if a player activated this the basketball court would become very slippery and the players on the other team would fall over all the time actually remember i remember being the target of this and playing the game and it basically renders the game impossible for you it's it's crazy i mean they put so many fun and clever things into this game. It's like, it's awesome. Yeah, it is awesome. And here's one that is awesome, but only if you're a Detroit Pistons fan. Going back to our buddy Mark Turmel, the programmer,
我的意思是，你知道的，这就是我会做的事。一样，这太棒了。这里还有另一个在游戏中很有趣的秘密彩蛋，罗曼，它叫“超级干净的地板”（super clean floors）。如果玩家激活了这个功能，篮球场就会变得非常滑，对方球队的球员会一直摔倒。事实上我记得，我记得自己曾成为这个功能的受害者，在玩游戏时，这基本上让游戏对你来说变得不可能通关。太疯狂了。我的意思是，他们在游戏里加入了这么多有趣且聪明的彩蛋。这感觉，太棒了。是的，确实太棒了。这里还有一个超棒的彩蛋，但前提你得是底特律活塞队的球迷。回到我们的好朋友、程序员马克·特梅尔……
the unstoppable player in the game and also programmer of NBA Jam. He was a Pistons fan, and he hated the Chicago Bulls. So a few years back, Turmell confirmed something to Sports Illustrated. If you were playing the Pistons against the Bulls and NBA Jam, it was a close game. The game was programmed so that the Bulls literally could not score a last second shot to tie or win the game. That is diabolical. I mean, this is, like, especially in a time period of the 80s and 90s, when the Bulls were this, like, huge dynasty, like, Michael Jordan was, you know, the goat.
游戏里不可阻挡的玩家，同时也是《NBA Jam》的程序员。他是个活塞队的球迷，而且他讨厌芝加哥公牛队。所以几年前，特梅尔向《体育画报》证实了一件事。如果你在《NBA Jam》里用活塞队对阵公牛队，而且比分很接近，游戏就被设定成公牛队在最后一秒绝对无法投进扳平或绝杀的球。这太邪恶了。我的意思是，这，尤其是在80年代和90年代那个公牛队是如此巨大的王朝时期，迈克尔·乔丹你知道的，就是历史最佳。
And I'm sure everyone wanted to play as the Bulls and to think that they couldn't win if they played against the Pistons is hilarious. It's really funny. But also, you couldn't play as the goat. So for years, Jordan would not license his name. to NBA video games. He wanted to retain his likeness rights, of course. So you could play as Scotty Pippen, Horace Grant, decidedly less exciting.
而且我确信每个人都想扮演公牛队，一想到如果他们对阵活塞队就根本不可能赢，这就太搞笑了。真的很好笑。但同时，你又不能扮演历史最佳。所以在很多年里，乔丹都不把他的名字授权给NBA电子游戏。当然，他想保留自己的形象权。所以你可以扮演斯科蒂·皮蓬、霍勒斯·格兰特，显然没那么让人兴奋。
And some basketball games, no offense, Scotty and Horace, but some basketball games actually had a generic player 99 instead of Jordan later on. So you could play kind of as generic Bulls player, which you could imagine as being Jordan. Yeah, you could pretend 99 was 23. Okay, so Roman, here's a final example. of the amazing strangeness of NBA Jam. There is actually a game inside of NBA Jam, the game, that has zero amount to do with basketball.
而且有些篮球游戏，无意冒犯，斯科蒂和霍勒斯，但有些篮球游戏后来确实用一个通用的“99号球员”代替了乔丹。所以你可以扮演某种通用的公牛球员，你可以把它想象成乔丹。是的，你可以假装99号就是23号。好的，罗曼，这里有一个最终的例子，展现了《NBA Jam》惊人的奇异之处。《NBA Jam》这款游戏里面其实还藏着另一个跟篮球毫无关系的游戏。
So you just break out and play another game. Totally different game, but it's one you might recognize. So in the arcade version of NBA Jam, you could access this second game where you play as a tank and have to drive around these different kind of three-dimensional geometric obstacles.
所以你只需要跳出来去玩另一款游戏。完全不同的游戏，但你可能会认出来。所以在《NBA Jam》的街机版本中，你可以进入这第二个游戏，在那里你扮演一辆坦克，必须在各种三维几何障碍物周围开着车转悠。
and I think you might recognize it. So here's what it looks like. Here's a playthrough on YouTube. Take a look. Totally, because this is a game that was inside the aforementioned skating rink in New York, Ohio. And this looks almost exactly like Battlezone. I mean, like, Battlezone had these vector graphics that I thought were absolutely gorgeous. In fact, if I were to create a game today, it would all be vector graphics to tell you the truth.
我想你可能会认出来。所以这就是它的样子。这是YouTube上的一个通关实况。看一看。完全如此，因为这是俄亥俄州纽约市前面提到的溜冰场里面的游戏。这看起来几乎和《战区》一模一样。我的意思是，《战区》拥有这些我当时觉得绝对华丽的矢量图形。事实上，如果要我今天来创作一款游戏，说实话，全部都会是矢量图形。
But it looks so much. Yeah, it looks like Battlezone. battle zone is a favorite of mine as well i don't know how you would play this game on roller skates roman because battle zone had those like two joysticks that you had to move but like you said like it looks like a game that is designed now if that makes sense even though it's it's so old there was this legendary cheat code in nba jam that allowed for this and to access uh this second game that was kind of a battle zone reference both players would have to hit x y z and pull down their joysticks at the same time. And then you could actually get into this tank game, which was really just an homage to Battlezone. That is so cool. And everyone using their joystick and buttons
但它看起来太像了。是的，它看起来就像《战区》。《战区》也是我的最爱之一，罗曼，我不知道你在轮滑鞋上怎么玩这个游戏，因为《战区》有两个你必须移动的操纵杆，但就像你说的，它看起来像一款现在设计出来的游戏，如果这说得通的话，尽管它已经这么老了。《NBA Jam》里有一个传奇的秘籍可以实现这一点，为了进入这个有点像《战区》彩蛋的第二个游戏，两个玩家必须同时按下X、Y、Z并向下拉动操纵杆。然后你就可以真正进入这个坦克游戏，这其实只是对《战区》的致敬。太酷了。每个人都用他们的操纵杆和按钮
in this way brings us nicely to our next episode. We're actually talking about video game controllers. That's right. Next time on Hidden Levels, one of the most elemental parts of video gaming, whether or not you're on roller skates, we are diving into the history of the joystick. There's a kind of direct manipulation quality to it. Do you want to move forward on a screen? Press the stick forward. Do you want to move backwards within the environment of the screen? Pull the stick backwards.
以这种方式完美地把我们带到了下一集。我们实际上将要谈论的是电子游戏手柄。没错。下期《隐藏关卡》将探讨电子游戏最基础的部分之一，无论你是否穿着轮滑鞋，我们都将深入探讨操纵杆的历史。它有一种直接操纵的品质。你想在屏幕上向前移动吗？把杆向前推。你想在屏幕环境中向后移动吗？把杆向后拉。
That is the next time on Hidden Levels from 99% invisible and endless threat. This episode was produced by James Parkinson, edited by Emmett Fitzgerald, mixed by Martine Gonzalez, original music by Swan Rial, Jamila Sandoto, and Paul Vikas. series theme by Swanreale and Paul Vitkis. Fact-checking by Graham Hesha, this story was adapted from James Parkinson's podcast, Gameplay. You can find a link to that show on our website.
这就是来自99% Invisible和Endless Thread的下期《隐藏关卡》。本集由詹姆斯·帕金森制作，埃米特·菲茨杰拉德剪辑，马丁·冈萨雷斯混音，原创音乐由斯旺·里尔、贾米拉·桑多托和保罗·维卡斯创作。系列主题曲由斯旺·里尔和保罗·维蒂基斯创作。事实核查由格雷姆·赫沙完成，这个故事改编自詹姆斯·帕金森的播客《Gameplay》。你可以在我们的网站上找到该节目的链接。
The managing producer for Hidden Levels is Chris Barube. Hidden Levels was created by Ben Brock Johnson from a loadrunner fever dream with power-ups and cheat codes thanks to the team at 99PI and Endless Thread. Endless Thread is a production of WBUR, Boston's NPR. The rest of our team, tackling Unsolved Mystery, Untold Histories and Other Wild Stories from the Internet includes My illustrious co-host Amory Severson, managing producer, Summa Tosci, editor Meg Kramer,
《隐藏关卡》的执行制片人是克里斯·巴鲁贝。《隐藏关卡》由本·布罗克·约翰逊基于一个带有能量道具和秘籍的跑酷狂热之梦创作，感谢99PI和Endless Thread团队。Endless Thread是波士顿NPR电台WBUR的制作节目。我们团队的其他成员致力于解决未解之谜、未竟历史和来自互联网的其他疯狂故事，包括我杰出的联合主持埃莫里·塞弗逊、执行制片人苏玛·托斯奇、编辑梅格·克雷默、
producers Dean Russell, Grace Tatter, and Frannie Monaghan, and sound designer, Emily Jankowski. And for 99% Invisible, Kathy Too, is our executive producer, Kirk Cole Stadis, the digital director of Delany Hall is our senior editor. The rest of the team includes Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Leigh, Lashamadon, Jacob Medina Gleason, Kelly Prime, Joe Rosenberg and me Roman Mars. The 99% visible logo was created by Stefan
制作人迪恩·罗素、格蕾丝·塔特和弗兰尼·莫纳汉，以及声音设计埃米利·扬科夫斯基。对于99% Invisible，凯西·图是我们的执行制片人，柯克·科尔·斯塔迪斯是数字总监，德兰尼·霍尔是我们的高级编辑。团队的其他成员包括杰森·德莱昂、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、薇薇安·李、拉沙马·唐、雅各布·梅迪纳·格里森、凯利·普莱姆、乔·罗森伯格和我罗曼·马尔斯。99% Invisible的标志由斯特凡·
Lawrence. The art for this series was created by Aaron Nestor. We are part of the SiriusXM podcast family. Now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building in beautiful uptown, Oakland, California. We have another episode of Hidden Levels on Friday. See you then.
劳伦斯创作。本系列的艺术作品由亚伦·内斯特创作。我们是SiriusXM播客家族的一部分。现在总部位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的上城区潘多拉大楼向北六个街区。我们周五还有另一集《隐藏关卡》。到时见。
Okay, here it goes. Boom, Shakalaka! There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
好吧，开始了。Boom, Shakalaka！本集目前还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可留下评论。